Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz Kumcu kız
demelerine sevindim Öncelikle
Şimdi ben resme başlarken tam olarak
böyle bir heyecanla başlıyorum
tuvali Karşıma alıyorum Tabii hayatımda
izlediğim görselleri işte dağları
ovaları insanları zihnime alıyorum
yeteneğim cebime alıyorum resme
başlıyorum ve hiçbir zaman o resim hayal
ettiğim gibi olmuyor ama Hayal
ettiğimden her zaman çok daha güzel
oluyor şimdi ben resim hikayeme ilkokul
olarak Ortaokulda katıldığım bir resim
yarışmasında aldığım dereceyle başladım
resim öğretmenleri çok önemlidir resim
alanında Çünkü
heyecanlı ve yenilikçi bir öğretmene
sahipseniz Gerçekten sizi alıp bir
yerlere götürür yarışmada kazandığım
derece ile bana dedi ki sen Güzel
Sanatlar Lisesi diye bir şey var
Oraya mutlaka katılmalısın dedi
nasıl olacağını falan bilmiyordum tabii
Ben Kırşehirliyim Kırşehir'in Mucur
ilçesinden bizim oranda Sadece düz
liseler ve kız meslek liseleri var Onun
dışında ilk defa hayatımda Güzel
Sanatlar Lisesi diye bir şey duydum beni
desen çalışmaları yaptırıp liseye
hazırladı ve birinci olarak kazandım
liseye başladığımda yatılı okudum
ailemin durumundan dolayı biraz paraya
kazanmam gerekiyordu O süreçte
üniversiteli öğrenciler projeleri için
yapmaları gereken resimleri bana
getiriyorlardı Ben de resimleri gece
uyumuyordum yapıyordum yaptığım
resimlerden ilk defa hayatımda para
kazanmaya başladım yani resimle para
kazanılıyormuş onu öğrendim
mezun olduktan sonra Anadolu
Üniversitesini kazandım Anadolu
Üniversitesi'nde de güzel bir dereceyle
kazandım
okurken üniversitede
yine çalışmak istedim yine resimden para
kazanmak istedim
tesadüfen oldu Eskişehir Anadolu
Üniversitesi Eskişehir'in yerel
gazetelerinden bir ilan gördüm ilanda
şöyle yazıyor resim yapmayı bilen kadın
eleman aranıyor Tam benim ihtiyacım olan
bir şey ben de gittim hemen görüşmeye
Ama bilmiyorum nasıl bir şey yapacağız
firma İnşallah dış cephelerinde
kullanılan kumlarla
yani kumları üretiyorlar oradaki
çalışanlarda bu kumlarla mozaik gibi
resimler yapmaya başlamışlar Fakat tabii
alaylı olunca bir yere kadar
geliştirebilmişler demişler ki bir
ilanla Biz hani güzel sanatlardan
birileri gelir Biz onları öğretiriz bizi
geliştirir Çünkü İyi de para kazanmaya
başlamışlar bu işten ben tabi çok kısa
bir sürede bu kum işini baya ilerlettim
Ondan sonra sürekli sipariş veriyorlar
falan bir yandan derslerime devam
ediyorum Bir yandan da işte yaz
tatillerinde hafta sonları gidiyorum
orada bir öğrenci için ciddi de bir para
kazanıyorum sonra benim üniversitedeki
hocam fark etti bunu dedi Halime sen
değişik bir şey yapıyorsun Ben gördüm
dedi arkadaşlarım bahsetti getirsene
dedi üniversitede yapalım biz bunu ben
de olur hocam dedim izin aldım işte izin
veriyorsanız üniversiteye getirmek
istiyorum dedim Ondan sonra da
üniversiteye Kumla resim tekniği
getirmeye başladım ilk defa Eskişehir
Anadolu Üniversitesi'nde sanat çalıştayı
düzenlendi bunda ilk defa işte benim
hocam yapmıştı dedi ki sana da ayrı bir
alan verelim yani ressamlar ünlü
ressamlar geldi Herkesin bir alanı var
ama sende yani orada farklı oldu ilk
defa anlamış oldum sen de orada teknik
göstermiş yol çalıştığı ayların en güzel
avantajı tanınmış ressamlarla öğrenciler
bir araya gelip Usta ressam
nasıl ilerlediklerini ve bakış açılarını
geliştirirler
kum resim orada bayağı etki uyandırdı
Fakat tabii üniversite hayatı boyunca
Hani resim okuyanlar iyi bilir sürekli
röprodüksiyon yaptırırlar böyle şimdi
ben röprodüksiyon yapa yapa lise
üniversite falan sürekli kopya etmeyi
çok iyi becerdim sürekli reprodüksiyon
yapıyorum
mezun oldum tabi okulda kalmamı falan
istedi öğretmenim ama evlendim Ben de
ondan sonra dedim ki yani nasıl olsa ben
her türlü her işi yapabilirim yine bir
resimle ilgili bir şey çıkartırım ama
dedim yani o zamanki sevdiğim eşimi
dedim bir daha bulamam yani evlendikten
sonra öyle bir yere gittik
Türkmenistan'a gittik falan yani 8
yıllık resim hayatım aslında bir yerde
bitti yani bir çok kadın bilir ki ya
çocuk yaparsın ya evlenirsin birçok
şeyden feragat etmek zorunda kalırsın
8 yıllık evliliğin sonunda Orada iki
çocuk yaptım İki tane de çocuğum var
dedim
Ruhumda bir şey eksik yani resimden 8
yıl ayrı kalmak ve yoğun çalışırken
sürekli bir şeyler üretirken uzak kalmak
beni hiç mutlu etmedi
Tabii Yolları ayırmak zorunda kaldık
fakat İstanbul'a geldik İstanbul benim
gözümde koca bir Derya Yani ben
Eskişehir'de
sınava hazırlanırken Mimar Sinan'dan
Korkardım İstanbul beni yutar diye
İstanbul'un ortasında iki çocuğunla
kaldım gibi hissettim bir an sonra
geçici bir iş buldum satış matış Çünkü
uzun süre piyasadan uzak kaldığınız
zaman işte arkadaşlarınız resim
öğretmeni olmuş Kimisi akademide
ilerlemiş falan filan sen o kadar
uzaklaşıyorsun ki sadece çocuk
büyütüyorsun
çok zorluyorsun Yani benim İstanbul'da
öğretmenlik yapmam bir okulun beni alıp
işte gel burada öğretmenlik yap
başvuruyorum cevap yok bende satış işi
buldum başladım satışla ilgili çalışmaya
güzel gidiyordu şöyle güzel gidiyordu
Beni sadece rahatlattı geçici olarak
Evet burada yaşayabilirim ve burada
çalışabilirim hissini verdi Fakat o da
dedim 8 yıl Ben resim yaptım hala ona
takılıyorum ya bunlar cebimde ama ben
gidiyorum başka her şeyde başarılı
olabilirim ama niye yeteneğimi verdiğim
emeğe çöpe atayım ki dedim Bir cesaret
cebimde param yok
yani Çok az bir birikmiş şeyim var ve
İstanbul'da Sefaköy diye bilen bilir
böyle Beylikdüzü gibi bayağı şehrin
dışında dedim ben biraz merkezin içine
gelmeliyim Bir hayal kurdum dedim ki bir
atölye açacağım
şimdi İstanbul'da resim alanında bir
şeyler yapacağım ama İstanbul koca bir
yer herkes resim yapıyor Bir sürü ressam
var İşte kimisi karakalem çalışıyor
Kimisi yağlı boya ama kumdan kimse resim
yapmıyor o zaman dedim ki ben Kumla
resim yapma üzerine bir atölye açayım
oradan bir fark yaratmak lazım diye
düşündüm kumdan
kumhane diye bir atölye açtım
nereden ilerliyor bu
geçtim
Tamam
moda da şehrin göbeğinde bir atölye
açtım orada resim dersleri vermeye
başladım ama bir yandan da sadece resim
dersi vermekle olmuyor Tabii ki yani
hayal ettiğin gibi gitmiyor Hiçbir zaman
hiçbir şey
kurslar veriyorum ama bir yandan da
Kumla Özgün çalışmalar yapmaya
çalışıyorum çünkü sergiler açmam
gerekiyor ki sanat camiasının içine
gireyim yani sadece resmin içine girmek
değil sanat camiasının İçine girmem
lazım benim
Belediyelerde Tabii ben bir de
Kırşehirliyim Ahilik Bizde çok şeydir
atölyeme gidip gelirken işte sınıfın
çayını içiyorum kahvesi içiyorum sohbet
ediyorum falan filan derken
belediyelerle böyle bir muhabbetim geçti
Dedim ben belediyelerle sergi açarsam
Belediyenin kendi reklamını falan beni
bir şekilde bir yere götürür Ama yani
kumdan Özgün çalışmalar yapıyorum ama
beni kimse bilmediği için senin Özgün
çalışmanı senin kişiliğini bilmeyen
insanlar hemen
anlamıyorlar Sadece bu nedir falan çok
güzel çalışmalar yaptım ama ben
bilinenden gitmek istedim ve benim
portrede çok iyiydim Atatürk portresini
çok iyi çalışıyordum dedim ki ben 19
Mayıs 23 Nisan Atatürk portreleri ile
sergi Açayım dedim
Tabii bu arada Kumcu kız diye adım
çıkmıştım odada
Atatürk portreleri ile sergiler açmaya
başladım Küçükçekmece Belediyesi'nde
açtım
kimse gelmedi ondan sonra Bakırköy
Belediyesi'nde açtım kimse gelmedi en
son dediler ki ckm'de aç Bağdat Caddesi
böyle şeyleri Sever iyi dedim oraya da
ulaştım ama bir şekilde bunlara ulaşmak
da zaten böyle bir zor yani öyle kolay
olmuyor Çok fazla şey yapıyorsun ona
resim veriyorsun ona resim veriyorsun
ona portre dağıtıyorsun falan en son
ckm'de açtım hem Özgün resimlerimle
bunlarla hem de bu şekilde
fakat yine satmadı ondansa da bir iki
tane böyle atölyeden satışların falan
oluyor
atölye battı yani ama yani çocuğum
gibiydi benim böyle çok üzüldüm dedim 8
metrekareydi orası da
şimdi çocuklarım var yaşamak zorundasın
resimle yaşamak istiyorsun resimde
hayatta kalmak istiyorsun ama imkanlar
ne yaparsan yap seni bir yere götürmüyor
gibi hissediyorsun Aslında sen öyle
hissetsen de seni birçok yere götürmüş
oluyor ama fark etmiyorsun Bugün bile
iki gündür buradayım Arkadaşlar biz
kumhaneyi biliyorduk dedikleri zaman
gerçekten ben belli bir yere gelmişim
orada Onu fark ettim
sonra tam böyle her şeyden vazgeçtim
dedim ben bu çocuklara da bakamıyorum
vereyim babasını
velayeti bırakayım ben dedim her yerde
sığınırım bir şekilde Yolumu Bulurum
dediğimi anda yine üniversiteden Hocam
dedi ki halime bir Çalış daha yapılıyor
Bu da 10'uncusu demek ki aradan 10 yıl
geçmiş Buna da katılmanı isterim En
azından ressamlarla tanış Kim ne yapıyor
bir görürsün dedi çalıştaya gittim orada
ünlü bir ressam dedi ki benim asistan'a
ihtiyacım var tabii ben hepsiyle
konuşuyorum siz ne yapıyorsunuz hocam
işte biri diyor ki resim öğretmenliği
yapıyorum öteki Akademi Herkes bir
yerden beslenip yani sadece işini
resimden yapan çok az ressam gördüm ve
herkes dedi ki kızım sen nasıl
yapıyorsun falan diyorlar Yani biz yani
Kaç yılın hocasıyız Biz bile bir
yerlerden destek alıp yapıyoruz ondan
sonra Vallahi dedim işte deli cesareti
ondan sonra
o hoca dedi ki İstanbul'a Ben yeni
taşınıyorum Ankara'dan gel dedi Benim
atölyemde bir insanlarla Tanış Yani asıl
sanat camiası içine gir satışlar nasıl
oluyor sergiler nasıl açılıyor Çünkü
benim öyle bir özel galeriye gidip böyle
bir CV'yi Versem mi kapıdan kovarlar
herhalde tanımıyorlar etmiyorlar belli
kişileri bilirler zaten bu camianın
içine giriyor çemberin içine
girdiğinizde anlıyorsunuz ki orada Evet
artık yeriniz var ama önemli olan o
çemberin içine girebilmek
Ondan sonra Hocanın yanında çalışmaya
başladım ilk gün bana şöyle bir şey
söyledi
kum resim
kalıcılığı kanıtlanmış olmadığı için
riskli bir iş sende de bırak bu işi
kızım dedi
Tamam dedim ben de bende de şimdi o
ayçiçek tarlaları yapıyor hasat
tarlaları yapıyor falan Sen de daha şık
tarzısın çok güzel yapıyorsun Ben
bugünden sonra ayçek tarlası
yapmayacağım Sen de bayağı iyi
yapıyorsun bunu gel dedi Bundan sonra
ayçiçek tarlaları yapmaya başla
bizde dedi hocalardan Hani öğrencilere
geçen bir şey olur tarzı olur Zaten sen
de benim ekolümü devam ettirecek kişi
olmalısın dedi Tamam dedim Ama tabi
böyle kendimle benimsetemedim Yani
buraya o kadar benimsemişim ki
başlangıçta böyle kopya yapıyorum hissi
beni rahatsız etti ama bir süre sonra
alıştıkça ben ona yorumlar kattıkça
Tamam artık o benim olmaya başlar gibi
oldu
hakikaten Ayçiçekleri tarlasına
başladığım anda bayağı güzel satmaya
başladım Bir de tabii O sayede sanatçı
Galericiler alıcılar kimler o güruhu
tanımaya başladım yani anladım ki ben o
çemberin içine girdim
en sonda da Hoca dedi ki fazla benimle
kalırsam kendinden çıkarsın artık sen
sen olmaktan çıkarsın dedi
kopyaya girersin Bence de artık Hani bir
buçuk yıldır birlikteyiz Sen de hani
maddiyatını düzelttin işte belli bir
şeye alıcı kitlesine ulaştım Artık tek
başına devam edebilirsin dedi Tamam
dedim ben de ayrıldım bu sefer dedim ki
sanatın merkezinde atölye açayım yani
seviyorum böyle yeni bir şey açayım
bütün Heyecanımı oraya vereyim gittim
Nişantaşı'nda atölye açtım sergi yaptım
tabii bu şeyden kurtulamadım işte
dediler ki bilmem neyin taklidi
açıklayamıyorsun da öyle diyorsun böyle
diyorsun falan yani
hocaya soruyorlar bir şeyler oluyor ama
yine de belli bir satış yaptım işte
belli bir resme geldim sonra böyle bir
şey yani fuarlara girdim fuarlarda devam
ettim
Yine bir sürü alıcıya ulaştım belli bir
kitlem oluştu ama o şey bende takıldı
kaldı yani o Halime değil yani oradaki o
özgünlük Savaşı kendi yaptığın şeyin
verdiği o gurur henüz gelmiyor yani bir
şey eksik diyorsun
sonra fuarları katıldım fuarlarda Tabii
fuarların şöyle güzel avantajları oluyor
dönükler alıyorsunuz Resimleriniz
üzerinde ilk defa fuara girdim Bodrum'da
fuarda bir gün Devrim Erbil geldi dedi
ki kızım sen çok yeteneklisin resimler
güzel ama bu kalıptan çıkmak için bence
en iyi olduğum şeyden devam et kum mu
diyorsunuz yoksa yok dedi kızım sen dedi
resmindeki en güzel şeyi büyüt Neydi o
en güzel şey
Bunlar ayçiçek tarlalarım çay tarlası
sende de ağaçları çok güzel yapıyorsun
dedi Bence bir tane büyük ağaç yap
ağaçtan devam et dedi Ben de ondan sonra
gerçekten böyle Bunlar tabi son halleri
ağaç yapmaya başladım ağaçlar böyle
artık yaptıkça beni mutlu hissettirmeye
başladı Bir baktım ben mutlu oldukça
hiçbir şey düşünmedikçe
Heyecanımı sadece ona verdikçe daha
Özgün daha güzel daha benden bir şeyler
çıkmaya başlıyor ve son süreçte Ben
artık tamamen ağaçlar üzerine yoğunlaşıp
bu zamana kadar ki bu yaşıma kadar ki
sanatçı
yolculuğumun burasındayım
şimdi tüm bunlar aslında büyük bir
cesaret işi Çünkü herkes bilir ki benim
annem bile hala yani iyi bir yerde
olmama rağmen yine de bir okullara
girsem mi kızım falan diyor sadece
resimle sadece Tutku duyduğun
insanların Yani para kazanılmaz gibi
meslek gibi görmediği bir alanla
hayatını devam ettirmek ve bunu
yükseltmek çok büyük bir başarıydı benim
için ve Öyle ki bugünlere kadar getirdi
beni teşekkür ediyorum dinlediğiniz için
[Alkış]
[Müzik]